I'm going to kick off uh with a viewer
question and this one is from Terry
Moore and the question is if you win
will you ask advice from Nicholas
sturgeon Ash I'll start with you of
course I would Nicola is a very
successful politician she has been at
the top of her game for many many years
now it's very unusual in politics to be
um in that at that high level for such a
long period so of course I would however
I think she's looking for other jobs
elsewhere so she may not be around for
much longer Snappy answer absolutely yes
she's exceptional
yes but I have to say it will be the
strangest feeling in the world answering
a question from Nicholas dungeon in the
back benches but yes absolutely what
about Alex salmon take advice from him
no no he's in a different party a rival
party so so no so no no no no so no one
takes advice from Alex summer but all
yes to Nicholas sturgeon let's start off
with you hamsa for this one is JK
Rowling a National Treasure
oh yes I think she's done amazing in
terms of the book she's written but I
disagree with her vehemently on the
issue of transgender race okay yes and I
do think she's Brave
do you disagree with how on the issue of
transgender rights no I don't disagree
with her you don't disagree that so you
so you back her on that Ash
um I think she's a National Treasure yes
I think she was very brave to speak out
on an issue where many women who had
raised legitimate concerns were
receiving you know quite threatening
Communications so yes she's uh
definitely a national truck okay and
I'll come chew for this one Gary lineker
has been reinstated as a BBC presenter
after the chaos of the last few days
should the director General Tim Davey
stand down well I certainly think he's
not done the BBC any services at a time
when already there is huge debate
freedom of speech is a huge question
mark in our society and I think the
whole process has been managed really
badly Ash I would agree with that I
think it has been managed badly and it
has not made the BBC look in a very good
light Tim Davis stay on go I think he
should well it's up to him he maybe will
want to consider that but it definitely
has put the BBC in um it looks like it's
in a bit of a conflicting position do
you remember given Gary lineker red card
the other night I did preface it by
saying that I hadn't actually seen the
tweets concerned and I thought it was
something to do with football
okay I'm so what do you think Tim Davis
the guy I genuinely don't think
government ministers acting and current
serving government ministers should be
interfering and who's in charge of our
public broadcaster or not Gary lineker
was absolutely right to make the remarks
he did and it's a heck of a world with
the main opposition is Gary lineker and
Carol vorderman at the moment bit more
power to both their elbows okay final
quick fire I'm going to go to you first
Dash Rishi sunako kirstama who's the
next PM
um I think that it was looking at the
moment that it might be Kirsten hey it's
highly late there'll be curious darmer
but one zatory and one's a pure
limitation of a story but I'll tell you
what I'll work with anybody to kick out
the Tories